[Music]  yes go ahead  well the whistleblower gave a very  inaccurate report and as you know  certain of the media released  information about a man that they said  was the whistleblower I don't know if  that's true or not but what they said is  he's an Obama person it was involved  with Brennan Susan Rice which means  Obama but he was like a big a big anti  Trump person hated Trump and they said  terrible things now I don't know if it's  true or not but that was reported by  some of the media so you'll have to find  out I don't know why the media is not on  it because the whistleblower gave a very  inaccurate report about my phone call my  phone call was perfecto it was totally  appropriate but the whistleblower should  be revealed because the whistleblower  gave false story some people would call  it fraud I won't go that far but when I  read it closely I probably would but the  whistleblower should be revealed  you